[Music]
hi and welcome to episode number 128 of
the weekly Google cloud platform podcast
I'm mark Mandel and I'm here with my
colleague as always Melanie Warrick
Melanie how are you doing today
I'm doing good mark how are you doing
I'm doing alright it's a Monday I know
and I'm back from Mexico City where I
was at the understanding risk forum
conference when I was pretty impressive
yeah it was really great that's awesome
we talked a lot about disaster recovery
actually which is really interesting
yeah and how to use tech to help with
disaster recovery but it's good to be
back
indeed this week we have Cassie close
rakov joining us to talk about decision
intelligence it's a super interesting
episode actually yes very much so and we
also have cool things of the week but we
finally we'll finish up with our
question of the week talking about how
you can secure your Google cloud
platform account using a Yubikey or
basically a physical device I like
anything around security so as you
mentioned mark we're going to start out
with the cool things of the week and
this week we wanted to bring up that TP
use are now available in beta on cloud
machine learning engine so if you want
to play around with the TPU you don't
have to sign up to get approved to have
access you can just go on to the machine
learning engine and set that up we have
a link to the information about this on
our show notes as always and one of the
links in particular will tell you
exactly how to set this up and also how
to use a ResNet model it gives a nice
little example of setting up a resident
model and running that on the machine
learning engine so check it out nice as
per always I have to talk about
kubernetes kubernetes 1.10 is now
generally available and ready for the
enterprise I love that tagline not only
you're getting the lovely new features
over 1.10 there's a bunch of new
features for gke including shared
virtual private cloud so VP sees I know
there's been a lot of requests for those
as well as node auto repairs
regional persistent disks and a few
other fun things so if you're looking to
upgrade to 1.10 now you can we also want
to mention that the ultramen Google
compute engine machine types are now
available and those are basically a
family of memory optimized virtual
machine instances and they come with a
lot more memory a lot what was it nine
hundred and sixty-one gigabytes 1920 two
gigabytes of memory and the 80 well you
mentioned the nine hair 61
memory and that's in the ultramen 40 and
it goes up to Ultraman 160 and it's got
three thousand eight hundred and forty
four gigabytes of memory and a hundred
and sixty CPUs and I know from turning
models in the past you love memory if
you can run a bunch of stuff in memory
it's it's pretty fantastic
there's many reasons in many cases out
there really being reddest instance just
a really really big loading all the data
up on machine doing all the calculations
fine and fantastic awesome no more
parallel computing not really finally
there was an article that came out on
the 15th of May titled increased
performance while reducing costs with
the new App Engine scheduler what's cool
about this is you don't actually have to
do anything if you're using App Engine
that's even better it's even better so
basically the new scheduler improves the
number of cold starts by 30 percent but
also reduces cost by seven percent so
all-around goodness yes and it also an
average of five percent reduction and
median and tail request latency 'he's
about saving time excellent saving time
is the best all right mark I think it's
time that we go and talk with Cassie
let's go do that
this week we're excited to have join us
Cassie kozakov who is one of our
teammates and she's here today to talk
to us about decision intelligence
welcome to the podcast
delighted to be here well I'm glad
you're here so Cassie I know we've
talked a little bit about this what
decision intelligence is and but before
we even get into what that is can you
tell us a little bit about yourself
sure I serve as chief decision scientist
for Google cloud and what I'm really
passionate about is data science plus
decision making together and you can
think of me as a sort of reformed
statistician if you will that's my my
core academic background supplemented
with psychology economics and
neuroscience and my experience before
this role was consulting academia and
data science great so why are you
passionate about decision making well
see anything we think we know knowledge
insights our impressions they only
really begin to matter when they drive
our action
so decisions are the way that we
interact with the world around us and
while some people might think of
decision-making as the way that you meet
your goals or beat your competition
there's really so much more to it than
that businesses and people who don't
know how to make decisions well are in
danger of having really large negative
impact on the world around them so I
think of decision-making as a way in
which we can build a better world for
all of us it's great so what exactly is
decision intelligence engineering I like
to think of it as data science plus plus
if you will or machine learning plus
plus it focuses on the applied aspects
of data science making decisions with
data and how to do that building
processes forgetting from the conception
of an idea to a data science project
running reliably and automating decision
making what is data inspired what does
that mean it data inspired is a sort of
joke about a serious subject it's a term
that we use around Google a lot that has
to do with not being data-driven when
you think you are let me give you an
example if I tell you that a hotel has a
star rating of 4.2 and then I ask you
whether or not you'd like to stay at
that hotel I have destroyed your ability
to be data-driven you can't use that
data that full point to to make your
decision that's because if you really
wanted to stay at this hotel all along
you will look at that full point too and
you will say hey that's more than full
point Sarah sure I'll go for it whereas
if in your heart of hearts you really
wanted to keep looking and go for a
different hotel you're gonna say what am
i some kind of animal to stay at a hotel
that's got less than 4.5 stars and so
the way that you interact with that
information will be driven by the
decision you want to make all along by
your unconscious biases
and not by the data itself so in order
for you to be data-driven the data has
to drive the decision and so you have to
have thought about what it takes to make
you wanna stay at the hotel versus not
before you see that four point to where
was your cut off was it four point one
was it three point five commit to that
early and upfront then look at the data
that's data-driven
where is data inspired is when we like
whales encountering plankton swim around
in some numbers and then we reached some
emotional tipping point and we decide
and sure there were numbers near that
decision somewhere it's just not the
numbers that drove the decision so that
decision would be at best data inspired
it sounds like as you talk through it a
lot of that is behavioral sciences as
well as data sciences why have those two
really combined here yeah so I think of
decision intelligence engineering as
augmenting data science with the
behavioral and managerial sciences and
the key here is that in order for us to
let the day to drive the decision that
decision context has to be framed
upfront so the decision maker has to
understand what it actually takes to get
them to want to do one thing versus
another and so that process where they
actually think through how they want to
make their decision that process isn't
taught in data science that's not an
engineering process that's taught in
behavioral psychology and in economics
that's about incentive design
cost-benefit analysis risk assessment
all the the subjects that are not
covered in typical data science courses
but definitely play a role and
absolutely those types of decisions so
for the decision makers and I know the
decision makers are you know can span
the company but especially those who are
more on the leadership side of things
how should they approach decision-making
so it's data-driven so they have to
frame their decision context care
fully and thoughtfully at the beginning
so here's where you want to start let's
take that hotel example your first move
is to think about how you would want to
make the decision if you could not get
any more information
you know nothing about the hotel are you
going to stay in it by default or not so
you have to commit to your default
action upfront your next move then and
this is where it takes a lot of training
and mental flexibility on the part of
the decision-maker is to think about
what information you would want what
information you would use if you could
have access to everything that's true
about the universe you were all knowing
so you have to think about framing your
decision context under full information
would you want to use the star rating on
average would you want to know how many
bad reviews or have people written about
bedbugs of what would you actually want
to know about this hotel in order to
make your decision and where is your
cutoff if you're using that average
stars review if you knew for a fact it
was 4.1 what would you do about it if
you knew it was for a fact 4.9 what
would you do then where is your cutoff
and you don't need data to do this you
need imagination but it's not easy and
then after you've dealt with full
information you ask yourself can I
actually have access to this information
I've requested or am I forced to deal
with only a partial view of reality not
the facts I wanted but a pale shadow of
them if I only have partial information
then I'm making the decision under
uncertainty then it is statistical and
then what I need to do is I need to
realize that I could make a mistake
uncertainty means well mistakes are
possible now and I could leave my
default action incorrectly but I might
also stay on my default action
incorrectly and then I have to think
about how I would balance the risks
there which one is worse than how much
worse how much risk am I willing to
accept and only after we've done all of
that can we go to a statistician and
have them help us move the rest of the
way
through making that data-driven decision
data science I know plays a role here
how do you define data science what is
that it's a lot of folks think that the
areas within data science descriptive
analytics statistical inference or
statistics for short machine learning
and AI are defined by the algorithms
used in them but that's not true if
you're a creative smart data scientist
you realize that you can use any
algorithm for any of these sub
disciplines and so really the difference
between them is how they are used for
decision making data science is just the
umbrella term that contains these three
things how they're used for decision
making is what separates them so let's
have a look if we're making no decisions
then we're doing descriptive analytics
the descriptive analytics is all about
asking what is here in my data so that
either we can make a fact-based decision
or we can just get inspired if we are
making one or a few important decisions
under uncertainty decisions with no
do-overs should we launch this product
yes oh no then that's a statistical
inference statistics for short and if we
are stitching a recipe for making a lot
of repeated decisions then that is
machine learning data science is the
umbrella that connects all three of
these together excellent so from a
decision intelligence perspective like
why should we be excited about machine
learning what does that bring to the
table so machine learning is all about
algorithmically creating recipes for
making decisions and we call those
recipes models what that really means is
that machine learning well it's a thing
labeler essentially that's what it is to
put it bluntly the reason that we should
be excited about that approach for thing
labeling as opposed to the traditional
one where a program has to think really
hard about the problem and then
handcraft the code that takes us from
the inputs to the label that we want is
that some tasks it's really really hard
to come up with the instructions for so
think about if you see a picture of an
animal and you just know the
it's a cat what did your brain actually
do to those pixels to get that label
it's really hard to describe what you've
done and so how could you possibly write
those instructions explicitly for the
computer your only hope is to try to get
that recipe stitched by giving the
computer a whole bunch of examples and
then saying to an algorithm a machine
learning algorithm figure it out make
that recipe for me because I can't
express it I think of this as giving us
the ability to automate the ineffable
and that's why we should really be
excited this is a fundamental leap in
human progress this unlocks a whole
class of tasks that we couldn't get
computers to do because we couldn't
explain to the computer how to do them
now we explain not with instructions but
with examples
I see machine learning always spoken
about in conjunction with artificial
intelligence and I know I have my own
perspective on this space but I'd like
to hear how you define artificial
intelligence how do you define AI so I
see a I typically spoken about one of
two different ways the first option is
to stay true to how that term has been
used throughout history and that means
staying true to how it was defined in
the 50s and sometimes I like to joke
that that version is what ever would
have impressed folks in the 50s and
whenever we end up building that
impressive thing maybe our calculators
today might have impressed them then we
just moved the goalposts further and
further away so that version is a little
unhelpful for my taste because it's both
everything and nothing the other version
what industry is really excited about
everyone wants to get into AI today
that's the version that I prefer as well
and to be more formal that version is
deep learning that is that part of
machine learning where the recipe of the
model could not possibly be stitched by
a human programmer there is no way to
solve that task except to go with
examples so a difference and to give you
a quick example here I like wine and
I have without any kind of data got a
little heuristic that goes something
like check the color of the bottle if
it's white don't bother if it's red
let's talk that kind of heuristic and I
imagine if I use data to try to predict
whether like a new bottle of wine I used
machine learning I might do a little
better than this hacky recipe that I
have the point is my recipe does okay I
can kind of take a stab at that task
that would be a machine learning task
whereas this version of look at the
image and figure out whether there's a
cat in it or not I have no idea how I
would even start expressing that recipe
so that one is AI I would have to use an
algorithm that's flexible enough and
sophisticated enough to just figure that
out from examples even though I can't
express it and that would be deep
learning I like that you're using a
recipe definitely a great way to express
it I used to use model like people in my
field do model this model that and then
I got feedback that not everyone
actually knows what that word model
nature but recipe I think we can all get
back what sounds like then that AI is
more applicable to decision intelligence
ml or like where does AI fit into this
so actually what I prefer for people to
do is to start with what tasks they want
to perform if they're going to apply it
and it's enough for you to figure out
whether or not you need machine learning
and if it so happens that you need the
deep learning algorithm you will end up
with an AI application and if you didn't
need it the right process might have you
use a much more lightweight algorithm
but you don't need to know in advance
whether it's the AI kind of machine
learning you just need a good process
for machine learning and then off of
that note what are some common mistakes
that you're seeing leaders make with air
or companies make with AI when we talk
about machine learning I think we do the
field a little bit of a disservice
because we make it sound like there's
only one discipline there but actually
there are two machine learnings and
they're two completely different
disciplines so maybe we should break
them up into research machine learning
and applied machine learning
and my analogy for this is the humble
microwave if I said that I were a
microwave a specialist microwave expert
you might think I'm a person who builds
microwaves maybe you'd think I know how
to innovate with microwaves in a
kitchens build recipes involving
microwaves he might not realize which
one I am this is the two different
disciplines the research machine
learning is about building the
microwaves general-purpose tools for
everyone to use and see you need quite a
lot of Education to get into that game
because how are you going to build a
better algorithm or for that matter a
better microwaves and the one that
exists already if you have no idea how
this one works you've never seen its
wiring diagram so for research machine
learning a lot of background it's all
about building those algorithms now on
the other hand if you're gonna innovate
in recipes actually use these things at
scale in an industrial scale kitchen you
need to know a bunch of things but
they're not the same as what you would
need in order to build the microwave I
mean think about this how does a chef
know that the microwave works and is
what they need certainly not by reading
the wiring diagram I'm pretty sure that
most chefs don't do that instead it's by
actually checking that it works and it
does what they want it to do and in
addition to having a microwave that
works tasting you know what it outputs
they need to have thought about what
they want to serve to their customers
they need to have thought about their
ingredients they need to have thought
about their process and how they've done
their taste tests and how they run that
whole kitchen so there's a huge science
on that side and the mistake that
leaders make is they don't see that
there's a difference between these two
and so what they try to do is they try
to build themselves a machine learning
team an AI team and they stuff that
entirely with researchers and that is
exactly the same as you want to run an
industrial scale kitchen and the only
people you hire are the folks who have
built microwaves their whole lives
those folks might not know anything
about cooking might have no empathy for
restaurant customers now sometimes
businesses luck out they've heard a
bunch of researchers and things turn out
okay
that's a happy accident that's because
in addition to the core skills taught in
a PhD those researchers ended up
developing love for the application
that's a whole other set of skills that
they got by accident and as our site
reliability folks say at Google hope is
not a strategy don't hope that your
researchers will just develop that
capability out of nowhere instead hire
for the applied kitchen hire for the end
to end process hire leaders who know
their business hire engineers who can
process and visualize those ingredients
that data wealthy hire statisticians who
can do that taste test and check that it
works on the other side and maybe you
don't even need the researchers because
academia Google cloud and other places
like that are building those microwaves
for you so as long as you know where to
go and shop for one take it and try it
out maybe you don't need to reinvent the
wheel build that thing from scratch
yourselves so leaders please don't start
by hiring the researcher only and hoping
that everything's gonna be great I like
that you brought up and and it's a
common major challenge trying to figure
out how to actually make the full
pipeline work but all these kitchen and
food analogies are making me hungry mark
so we talked a little about common
mistakes but where then should leaders
actually start what's it what's a great
starting point before you even hire
anyone leaders you have a job to do this
process should always start with you and
in machine learning the first thing you
need to think about is what outputs is
your system gonna make machine learning
is essentially a thing labeler so what
do you need labeled and if you can't
even think of what you need labeled
diving right into machine learning is a
little too soon for you maybe you want
to do some descriptive analytics and
hopefully we'll get a chance to chat
about that soon but imagine in this wine
example you want to build yourself a
wine classifier well what do you want
this system to output for you maybe I'll
like it or I won't like it on a new
bottle of wine you have to be able to
say what those outputs should be
and then you need to think about how you
would measure success and what mistakes
are possible and there are really a lot
of options here decision makers maybe
you're after accuracy all mistakes are
equally bad as far as you're concerned
missing out on a good bottle or getting
a bad bottle same to you but maybe you
are a starving grad student I've been
there and money is really precious and
you're quite happy to miss out on good
wines but if the system says buy this
one you don't want it to waste your time
well that's a different metric from
accuracy that one is called precision
maybe on the other hand you're now past
your graduate school years and now
you're really worried about missing out
on the good beautiful wines you would
have liked well
now you're after Rico which is a
different thing entirely of all the
beautiful ones that were there how many
did it return correctly for me so you
have to think about how you want to
measure success and then what you need
to do going back to being data-driven
you need to make sure that you can be
data-driven at your launch don't launch
decision at the end so you need to
commit to your minimum performance
criterion if you picked accuracy where's
your minimum cutoff for letting the
system see the light of day is it 80%
accuracy is it 70% you must commit
upfront and what you'll realize leaders
you can do all of this without any data
without any employees without any
equations or textbooks this is just you
meditating in a closet and so everyone
who's listening here you can now start
thinking about what would you label if
you had an awesome thing labeler and so
you can all get started on this and if
anyone asks you are you doing machine
learning you can with a completely clear
conscience say absolutely yes I am
because you are doing the right first
step in the applied process off of that
note is there any additional advice that
you would have especially for the data
science teams so I find myself repeating
three words over and over it's it's
become a sort of slogan and that is
split your data data splitting is a way
that
you can have your cake and eat it too in
data science so when we talked about
data-driven we saw that if you've
already seen the data then at best your
decision based on that data will be data
inspired when I should be driven by the
data because if you use the data to
decide what question to ask off the data
well you know you see what you get the
trouble is you can't use the same data
set for both inspiration and rigorous
data-driven decision-making so what's
the quick hack well you've got one data
set you need more than one data set so
turn one data set into more than one
into an exploratory piece and a test
piece that lets you have your cake and
eat it too
is now what you do is you give the
exploratory piece to everyone in the
organization no matter their education
level and everyone can go do some
descriptive analytics on it it's 10
second lecture on descriptive analytics
is plot all the things but stay
skeptical so you don't need a whole lot
of educational background just have a
look at what's in the data and if you
can't look at all of it look at the
first five entries that's better than
nothing just get inspired the only
mistake you can make during exploring
data is taking yourself too seriously
we humans are really good at finding
patterns will find Elvis and a piece of
toast and we shouldn't take that
seriously and so here you have your
entire organization looking for tasty
tidbits of insight in this exploratory
set what they're sort of doing is
baiting a hook that they're gonna fling
into the ocean where decision-makers
swim we're going to try to get
decision-makers to react to that
information and make a decision and
decision-makers will for the most part
completely ignore that plot and make
their decisions some other way that's
fine that's par for the course but every
now and then that data insight makes the
decision-maker one a bite and take an
action and if that's not such a very
important decision well you know fling
that fish back into the ocean and make
the decision based on inspiration that's
fine we're allowed to make decisions
based on intuition as long as we're
honest with ourselves about it but if
that's a
really important decision then the
decision-maker might not want to run
headlong into the wall based on Elvis
found on in a slice of toast they want
to make sure that this is something
worth taking seriously they want to
approach the decision rigorously well
then they can use that inspiration to
frame their decision context and that's
really easy to do because they know what
they were doing before the insight came
in they know how they thought about
changing their minds in response to the
data they know what it is about it that
made them want to change their minds and
then they can go to the other data set
and have their experts check that it's
actually worth taking that action that
we should take it seriously and
statistics really is the science of
changing your mind so you'll bring the
statistician in and see if it's worth
actually reacting to that piece of
insight so split your data now why
haven't people been doing this all along
until fairly recently it was hard enough
to scrape together enough data for one
respectably sized dataset never mind
more than one but now as the world is
generating more and more data most of
our listeners I think have no excuse not
to split their data you've got so much
don't be stingy make two datasets use
one for inspiration and use the other
one for making decisions well so what
would you say to data scientists who are
worried about exploring these data sets
but they don't necessarily have that
deep educational background what do you
suggest for those sort of people
welllook exploration is supposed to be
sloppy we don't want to come to
conclusions here we don't want to take
ourselves too seriously again we're
looking at that piece of toast and we're
seeing if we find Elvis in it or not
this isn't the stage where we get
records and so actually I'd like to
rather say to data scientists think you
need a deep educational background here
to please calm down a little bit and not
bully everyone else the skills that you
need for doing this bit are exactly the
same skills that you use for looking at
photographs and by the way photographs
are stored as data they are not stored
as this beautiful visual thing that you
can make sense of and the when you take
those numbers that photographs a stored
as and you visualize them with
appropriate software I don't know
paint or Google photos or what have you
then you can begin to get inspired but
you must never take that photograph too
seriously if you've just walked down the
street and you find some photograph
lying around
don't go learning all kinds of things
about the world based on it you don't
know anything about where it came from
the best that you can do is say this is
what is here and so as long as everyone
has the discipline to plot it and stick
to well what we learned is that this is
what's here and maybe we might be
inspired we shouldn't take ourselves too
seriously let's not come to conclusions
on this until we've gone to the other
data set then it's fine so everyone
should be allowed in and empowered to
just go for it you already have the
right skills what you're doing with
digital photographs it's what you should
be doing with all the rest of the data
sets the funny thing is though the data
scientists may have a habit many of them
no I think they I should say we because
I was guilty of this when I just
finished my statistics graduate training
we spend a long time in school getting a
gold star
every time that we use the most
complicated tool in our Arsenal and so
when we leave after years and years of
that reinforcement our comfort zone our
natural behavior is to keep doing the
most sophisticated thing possible the
most rigorous thing possible and we even
kid ourselves that we are saving
rescuing decision-makers in some way
because decision makers don't even know
that they need this well look in the
exploratory phase taking ourselves too
seriously has no place so don't be
rigorous for its own sake there take it
lightly do things quickly and when we're
moving from the exploratory phase to the
data-driven decision-making phase in the
other data set that should be kicked off
by the decision maker and the decision
maker is the one who's had the training
to think about well how scared should we
be how should we trade risk how
important is this how much rigor is
required because they don't teach that
in a data science computer science
statistics training program so everyone
should be allowed in and don't do
for its own sake decision-makers should
kick off the rigor great I know we're
getting a little short on time but I
wanted to give us the chance to dive
into it just a couple of things one
question that definitely comes to mind
people are interested in decision
intelligence what are some of the
resources where do you recommend that
they go to to start exploring the space
so decision intelligence engineering is
a practice that we've put a lot of
effort into developing at Google and
we've got a lot of training and
resources internally but there's not a
lot out there externally when I went
about getting my own training I had to
have full immersion in a whole lot of
separate degrees I had to study
statistics separately from psychology
separately from economics separately
from neuroscience that's an awful lot of
schooling time sometimes I think I
wonder about my life choices but we
can't expect don't we all right we can't
expect everyone out there who's
interested in this to go and pursue full
degrees and a whole bunch of different
disciplines so this is not that much out
there and we've been developing it in
here we've decided to start sharing a
lot of resources with the world sharing
what we know so stay tuned watch the
space there'll be a lot of information
about decision intelligence coming soon
follow you on twitter sure I feel like
was there anything else actually you did
want to say in terms of decision
intelligence decision-making that you
know we haven't had a chance to cover
especially you know you've had some
wonderful analogies but was there
anything else you wanted to touch on yes
I want to talk very briefly about some
challenges in AI when we move from a
research machine learning to applied
machine learning as our focus we move
from how does the microwave work so we
can build a better one - does it work so
that I can serve my customers well and
solve my business problems now how does
it work sounds easy but it isn't because
there are three things we have to deal
with there what does it mean to work
what is the it that we're trying to do
then that is on decision makers
then the does it work that is on the
statisticians working with the
decision-makers actually making sure
that it delivers and the last bit the
sort of hidden bit is that in any
kitchen in the data science kitchen as
well your ingredients matter on what
ingredients does it work if you put bad
ingredients that data in you shouldn't
expect good results out on the other
side what I like to say about machine
learning is that the world represented
by your training data is the only world
that you can expect to succeed in think
of your training data a little bit like
textbooks that your student might study
from maybe you want to teach your
student that in calculus and give them a
bunch of textbooks to learn from the
examples in those textbooks world
represented by them is the only thing
that that student is going to learn from
that process just cuz you have data it
just cuz you have textbooks doesn't mean
your students going to learn calculus
open that textbook and check that what's
in there is calculus and not I don't
know Japanese English vocabulary pairs
because your students gonna find some
patterns in there sure and stitch a
recipe that connects Japanese with
English it just won't be relevant to
your task so your ingredients really
matter so please make sure that you have
thought about what it is that you have
checked that it does work before you
release it and that you've thought
really carefully about your ingredients
and split your data that's great well
thank you Cassie I appreciate you
joining us again on the podcasts
especially to give us this robust
perspective on decision intelligence
thank you again thanks so much it was a
lot of fun to be here thank you thank
you again Cassie for coming on the show
and talking to us about decision
intelligence
yeah really interesting conversation
super interested to hear more about the
research that you're doing in the space
agreed all right mark how can I secure
my GCP account using a UV key so I'm
sure many of us or but if you haven't
that's totally fine I've heard of say
things like two-factor authentication
right so you want to have a password for
something like I think you know and you
want to have a thing you have like say a
through your email or sometimes it's a
text or it's a phone call but it's
if your password in combination with
something else yeah and so there's also
these devices like security keys what
you may have heard you be keys for
physical devices that you can be used as
a two-factor authentication basically is
that thing you have some of them are
shaped almost like a thumb drive yeah
but they're not a thumb drive in terms
of holding actual data on them but their
way of proving that you exist and that
you are next to the device that you're
using what you can do is basically you
can secure your Google Cloud account
that gives you access to Google cloud
platform using all these actual options
so you can actually do it through you
can have two factor authentication using
text messages there's a Google
Authenticator which is a rolling number
that you can use as a two-factor
authentication you can have on your
Android and iOS devices as well as
security keys themselves we'll have a
link in the show notes and describing
how you can do that but what that ends
up happening is is when you say do AG
cloud or login so you're doing like a G
cloud authentication or you're trying to
do something through the console it asks
you for your two factor auth when you
log in so that your authentication it
has that extra layer of security yes and
you be keys in particular are up and
coming in the security field so seen as
more secure in comparison to like
receiving a text so if you have the
opportunity to use that I know you can
use that on a number of different sites
that you can log into like github for
example you should explore it your Gmail
but definitely look at that for the
Google cloud something else we wanted to
give a shout out to is one of our
community members actually wrote a blog
post not exactly the same thing but
still interesting where he wanted to
experiment with encrypting his G cloud
credentials on his laptop using a UB key
and this was from Salman Rashid and he
basically explored he even says us in
the post which is kind of great is that
you know this is not really a practical
use of it but if you have application
credentials on your laptop that you
wanted to try encrypting with the
Yubikey orsucci smart card the GPG smart
card is the Yubikey is my understanding
or close enough
anyway he takes you through steps on how
to do that encryption and tells you you
know where to find the different files
and what files to change and will
include that link for those who might be
curious to explore this and experiment
and play around with it and get more
comfortable with ub keys yeah it's
pretty neat he really does he kind of
hacks the hood so
any time he does a g-cloud operation he
has to hit his ubk to make sure it works
one thing distressed that he points out
in his article and you definitely want
to do this is make copies and back up
the actual access tokens because you
will not want to lose those if for some
reason your encryption works but there's
something that gets broken along the way
use at your own risk
exactly exactly and again not
necessarily something that you need to
do but also just sort of a fun external
thing to play with
yeah yeah all right mark you're gonna go
anywhere in the next month a couple
months so I will be presenting at a
monthly San Francisco game development
community at the meetup here in San
Francisco so I will be doing that on the
30th of May doing my talk called you
can't just add more servers yes yeah
can't you can't that's great you can be
speaking every month on that what do you
have - next month I will on June 26 I
will be speaking at an event that's
being co-hosted by the women and machine
learning in data science and PI ladies
at door - so we will be doing a couple
talks on careers and data science yes
yeah excellent
well Melanie thank you so much for
hanging out with me for yet another
podcast
thank you Mark thank you all for
listening and we'll see you all next
week
[Music]